I'm Tim Jakes and I am Scoutmaster with Troop 93 in Westchester, Pennsylvania.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me
And now the old Scoutmaster.
Hey, everybody, this is Clark Green. It's summertime and so our next few podcasts feature on-core presentations
from our archives, and this week is an interview with somebody who kind of defies categorization.
His name is Andrew Skirka and I think it's safe to say that he is the most incredible
long-distance backpacker and hiker in living memory.
Andrew's book, The Ultimate Hikers Gear Guide, is a really amazing resource for anybody
who's going backpacking or hiking.
As always, this podcast is only possible because of the generosity of the folks who become
ScoutmasterCGcom backers.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page.
You'll find out how you can become a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
We'll be back with our regular schedule of podcasts in a few weeks.
Until then, let's get started, shall we?
Andrew Skirka has won a lot of attention for his solo long-distance backpacking trips.
For instance, he hiked a 4,700-mile six-month expedition in Alaska and the Yukon,
which would be like a lifetime achievement for most of us,
but that was basically one of the shorter ones.
He covered 6,875 miles in seven months following the Great Western Loop
in the United States, but that's still not the longest one.
He walked 7,775 miles- just saying that makes my feet hurt-
in an 11-month sea-to-sea route across the US,
and he figures that in the last decade or so he's covered 30,000-plus miles
and that's the equivalent of traveling 1.2 times around the Earth's equator.
He's been named Adventurer of the Year by both Outside and the National Geographic
Adventure Magazines, as well as Person of the Year by Backpacker Magazine.
He's also the author of the recently published Ultimate Hiker's Gear Guide
from National Geographic,
And if you look at your March April edition of Scouting Magazine,
there he is right there on the cover.
I'm happy to welcome Andrew to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Good morning, Andrew. How are you?
Hey, good morning. Thanks very much for having me.
Well, no, I really appreciate you spending the time.
How in the world did you end up doing this?
I think I sort of stumbled into it.
I never set out with the intention of making this into a lifestyle,
but I did my first long-distance trip
One. I was still in college. It was 2002..
I did the Appalachian Trail and then, after graduating, I did that sea-to-sea trip
and I think things just sort of escalated from there
And I was fortunate that I had never developed any extensive habits
or taken on any extensive responsibilities
and that kind of allowed me to be like a dirtbag hiker, if you will,
Kind of like a dirtbag climber, but I was hiking instead
and slowly over time I was able to build it into something
that was economically sustainable as well.
We're talking with volunteer scout leaders and we're all parents.
So you are getting ready to graduate from college-
You were at Duke right,
Correct?
And you decide that you're going to go and do a through-hike of the Appalachian Trail.
Is that, if I have the timeline right there,
Yeah, I get it before I graduate.
It's actually between semesters-
My son's name is Andrew, by the way,
And he came to us in the fall semester of his junior.
He says: you know what?
I think? I'd like to go and spend three or four months on the Appalachian Trail.
How did your parents react to that when you told them that you had this great idea?
The Appalachian Trail was part of our larger plan,
So the economy at the time was pretty bad.
It was just difficult to find anything worth doing for the summer,
So I kind of pitched it as something I could do this summer,
that I could sort of knock off my bucket list
and that way, when the economy is a little better
and my odds of finding something worth doing were better,
I would be available for it.
And they were thrilled about this.
They weren't thrilled but they were okay with it.
The plan made sense then
And they just didn't expect that when I did the Appalachian Trail,
that that wasn't going to be enough.
So the trip that they really, the trip that they really got upset about,
was that sea to sea trip, because that was, you know,
instead of doing something with my $150,000 education,
I was instead, you know, in their view,
sort of pissing it away by taking on this. you know,
I don't know how they were characters, useless, dangerous,
Useless, dangerous, crazy,
Yeah.
But I think my feeling on it was that I was at the one point in my life
where I really could do something like this.
I was young, I didn't have any responsibilities,
I hadn't committed to a career, to a woman, to a home,
I hadn't done any of that stuff.
So I was going to do anything like that.
That was the time
And I stuck with that decision because I had made the realization
that these lifestyle decisions are mine to make
And there's a lot of pressure from society, from parents,
from peers, to take that very conventional track
which is, you know, your college degree, job,
house or wife, house, kids,
Right,
And there's a lot of pressure to do that.
And I had made this realization that if I wanted to make
a different decision I could do that,
And you know. so the message I see in that for us folks is:
listen to your kids carefully,
Listen to what their plans are, what they're thinking about,
And hey, you know, down the road, look what can happen.
The traditional way out is not the only way out,
And Andrew's a real good example of that.
I'd also add, if I could, I think I'd also add that
I think any experience in which your child is putting themselves
out of their comfort zones and is having an opportunity to grow
will probably be a good thing in one way or another.
Absolutely, I absolutely agree with you
And I think scouting we try, we kind of major in that,
putting people outside their comfort zone in a lot of ways.
So you talk about the first real backpacking trip. you went on
as being that. you left. you set out from Springer Mountain
in Georgia on the Appalachian Trail.
How did that go?
Oh, it was bad.
It was bad.
So it was my first congressman's trip.
It was my first backpacking trip,
And now I describe myself as a camper by default,
which is a backpacker that takes too much,
because they're basically packing their fears.
They justify a lot of your decisions on the ground
of what if or just in case,
And they just don't know.
I also shared a lot of conventional gear,
which is because I just didn't know any better
And I thought that what the industry was telling me
and what an REI catalog was telling me,
that that was the right thing.
And then finally I had. no, I wasn't able to use any gear
that required any special thought or skill to use.
Like everything had to be foolproof.
So I wasn't capable of setting up the tarp,
So I had to use a dev wall pen.
I didn't know how to. I didn't know how to select a good campsite.
I didn't know how to pack a bag.
I didn't know how to pack a bag correctly.
So it was like it was necessary that I had like some big,
you know bombproof suspension pack where it didn't really matter
how I loaded it,
It was in there and it all sort of fit at the same.
I didn't know any skills.
So that was kind of like three main problems.
And unfortunately, a lot of beginner and, to that matter,
I think, still a lot of intermediate backpackers are like that
And their experience is just so miserable
that their hiking experience is so miserable
that they end up just wanting to camp
because they just they can't enjoy hiking.
I think that your experience that you had
is played out in a slightly smaller scale,
like hundreds and hundreds of times every year
They give this a shot and then they,
tens of thousands of times,
Tens of thousands of times-
Yeah,
They're 20,000 kids who go through film on every summer
and probably of those, probably 19,000 of them
probably are not doing it right.
You go into detail about that experience
and kind of the evolution that you went through
as far as the selection of gear and everything
and your philosophy and your approach to these trips
in the Ultimate Hikers Gear Guide-
And I have read the book,
I've looked at it.
Folks, you will have seen, yesterday
I posted a review of the book in advance
of being able to talk to Andrew here on the podcast.
It's really a game changer.
I think it's a great piece of work
And I think it's going to make things really
really work for people.
If they'll go and look at the book and follow your advice,
I think we're going to see a whole lot more successful
backpackers developed out of it.
I certainly hope so.
The way I've been presenting it is basically,
I think I look at it as a $20 investment.
I've traveled, as you said
in the introduction, I've gone like 30,000 miles.
I've made a lot of regrettable purchases of gear.
I've made a lot of mistakes and suffered as a result
because I chose the wrong stuff
or I didn't have the skills to use it properly,
And I've also made some really good decisions
that I've learned a lot along the way. in the book
I share that
The focus is on backpackers who want to enjoy hiking.
I think that there's plenty of information about there.
for backpackers who want to enjoy camping,
They can take it like read a book by Knowles.
Knowles specializes in camping.
They're basically car campers that are mobile.
There isn't that much information on a mass scale
about if you actually want to enjoy hiking,
which is different.
You're moving,
You have to carry all of your stuff,
And that's kind of been what I've specialized in
is trying to figure out how to enjoy
the walking aspect of all these trips I've gone on.
That's like this connection that people don't make.
That's why I think the book is a real game-changer.
that comes at it from the idea of trying to define,
like, where you are
And then if you want to get to the point of
being able to backpack comfortably, you know
here's what you do.
If you want to end up being an ultimate hiker,
if you want to really challenge some big experiences,
you know here's what you end up doing.
And you know I read the part in your introduction
that you were kind of aiming at trying to do
the complete walker- Colin Fletcher's-
the complete walker for this century-
And I think you made it
Well. I appreciate that reference.
Yeah, that's definitely my objective.
Colin's book is:
They're awesome books.
They changed the way that people backpack.
Unfortunately, we now have our disposal
New gear, new supplies, new techniques
that allow us to do it differently and to do it better,
And that was my idea in writing the book.
Yeah, well, I think you were successful
in kind of helping to redefine
exactly what we're doing out there
and how we make it happen. well,
One of the things that I first saw about you
was the YouTube video
And it really made me anxious to talk to you,
And this video is when you encounter
the porcupine caribou herd,
Right,
And where were you at the time?
I was up in the Yukon, Arctic,
So like basically far north,
Far northwestern Canada.
So you have, like, this moment-
I don't know exactly how to describe this moment-
a moment of enlightenment or clarity
or some kind of transcendent moment.
Can you share that with us?
Can you explain what happened?
Yeah, I still struggle to explain it, to be honest,
But basically I've been so worn down
by what I was going through
And at the time I was in the middle of a 657-mile
24-day stretch without crossing the road
and without seeing a human being,
And I was just getting beat up
on a regular basis by big floods
and bears and mosquitoes,
And I was just so worn down by those elements,
in addition to just this larger sense of exposure
and risk and self-dependence, that I,
when I came up on a porcupine migration trail corridor,
which is this very visible track across the tundra,
I just broke down and realized,
or not realized, but felt like I was tapping into their energy
And I knew that this was a species
that, for their survival, has this journey
plus a year where they migrate back and forth
from their wintering grounds to their migrating grounds,
And when they're on that journey,
they are just basically eating, sleeping and moving.
And for me it was the same thing,
And I had this sort of connection with the caribou,
where I was just one of them.
I stopped being some elevated species,
I was just another animal, first in this landscape,
that was having the same experience
that they was looking over my shoulder.
I was trying to send myself off from those variables
that I listed before.
It was a pretty amazing moment
And definitely not something that had happened before
and not something that would have been possible
if I hadn't really
almost only intentionally worn myself down
and just wasn't unable to keep my guard up
to have that experience.
Yeah, I think adventurers and campers-
I mean you can go car camping
and you can get a glimpse of this experience-
And I think, if you've been out in the woods
enough times, anybody who's listening
has had a little glimpse of this type of thing.
that's really, really hard to explain.
I mean, I imagine you're going to spend the rest of your life
trying to figure out exactly what happened to you there.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah, I'm actually not sure if there's just someone
who backs out in the lower 48.
Well, I don't know,
It's hard to say.
I mean, I think the key feeling is just feeling
like your life is on a string.
I think that's the best way to describe it.
So if you wander into your backyard
and it's such a security place
where you feel like your life is on a string
and, yeah, you kind of get a glimpse.
But I would say that a lot of
if you were to just drop yourself down in a helicopter,
exactly where this happened to me,
you probably wouldn't feel that,
You probably wouldn't get that sense,
because they're just like you hadn't.
I think part of maybe the only experience
that was having gotten there
under my own power
and having had all those prerequisite experiences.
Yeah, this is what I think is so important
about getting outdoors
and about camping
and pushing yourself and challenging yourself
in these situations
is you find things out about yourself
that you would not find out otherwise.
That's certainly one of them.
You confront yourself and nature
and whatever your set of the religious way
that you look at the world,
you confront that on a very basic level
And this was something that has been
one of the intentions of scouting
since it was founded
was to get in the outdoors
and to be able to learn these things
And whatever these things are.
they're really really hard to define,
But I think anybody who's had
even a glimpse of that experience.
So right now you've written the book,
You're on this like crazy long speaking tour.
What's the next big adventure?
Of course
It tends to be a three-year cycle.
After going on a big trip
the first year, I take off
and just try to get some semblance
of a normal life back,
Because it would be the Alaska trip
that was six months of doing,
six months of planning
And even before I left
my friends were saying:
hey, have you left for your trip yet?
Because I haven't seen you in two months.
So it's important for you to come back
and try to get a semblance of a life back
and just try to re-achieve some balance.
Year two: I usually go out
and do some smaller trips
and build up some different skills
and explore some new areas.
And then year three,
after having had that, hopefully
like a sort of a light bulb moment
and aha moment,
in year two I do a big trip into three
This year or this go around.
it looks like it's going to be a four-year plan.
I basically writing the book
was an adventure of its own.
It took thousands and thousands of hours of work
And I'm also, as you've mentioned,
I'm on this big 50 event speaking tour right now.
So it's.
it took me a little longer to go on a big trip,
but I'd expect to go on another one-
We'll see.
Yeah,
And I felt like I'm not getting out.
I mean, this year I'm guiding.
I'm guiding probably about 75 days worth of trips,
So I'm doing a bunch of three-day trips
that are all around the country
and that sort of helps
and ties me over to a different challenge of its own
in terms of really understanding people
and team dynamics.
And it's also a lot of responsibility
taking a group out in the wilderness
and being responsible for not only their safety
but, just as importantly, their happiness
with their experience.
And if people are interested
in looking into that
andruskerkacom is that where we go?
That would, yeah,
And there's a link to my guided trips
And it said you know
any.
there are some
three-day trips in particular would be helpful
for a lot of,
a lot of scout parents and scout masters.
They're learning intensive experiences where we
we don't hike that many miles- no more than five,
And it's all three days
probably do like a five and a 10 and a five
And that's about it.
But the whole emphasis is on
is on learning about different shelters,
different clothing systems, clothing systems
out there,
And then, once we're out there,
we'll do things.
do things like hiking, efficiency.
But we had us kind of spending a lot of time in camp
and learning this stuff,
With the idea being that you can,
you can hike on your own time.
Where are they?
And ballpark the cost for me,
Sure.
So there's seven different locations.
There's Northern California
physical national forest,
White Mountain National Park in Hampshire,
Olympic National Park in Washington,
Quartz Pine Mountain State Park in
in the UP of Michigan,
I think, and right around National Park in Colorado.
The cost is $600, which is
comes out $200 a day,
which is actually quite a bit less than a typical nose
nose course which I'll run yet
run at about $230 a day.
And my assistant guides
are equally,
equally qualified.
One co-founded backpackinglikecom.
Another was the first to hike
the triple crown in a single calendar year.
So he did the Pacific Cross, Death Placent Trail
and Pacific Cross
or Council of I-Challel on a year,
And then the other is actually
the Mills Instructure for 20 years.
So it's a really qualified group,
And there's also discounts available
if you sign up with more than one other person
or if you sign up for a three-day trip
and a seven-day trip.
So well, listen,
one of these days I'll get you back to talk again,
But I really do appreciate you spending the time today.
All right, sounds good. Thanks, Clark.
Thank you,
Thank you for listening to this
277th edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Go to scoutmasterscgcom
and there you can read our blog
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can join the other mobile scouts
who have the Scoutmaster CG app
on their mobile devices
and you can get the app in the Google Play
or iTunes App Store.
You can experience all the wonders
that are scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
Join the 9,500 folks who like Scoutmaster Blog on Facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 1,200 tweeters on Twitter
and pin the poultry tuna's pictures
that we profit publicly,
with 1,900 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch as it's Scoutmaster CG on YouTube,
or join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive and very quiet
Scoutmaster CG Circle on Google Plus.
Now, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better,
if you've no interest in Pinterest
if you don't put the? U in YouTube.
if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus,
don't worry about it.
That's okay,
Bunky, Zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
You can get in touch with me, Clark Green,
at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
And let me remind you, please,
that the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of anybody
except for myself.
Nope, they're not official publications
of any scouting organization
like the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by anybody.
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good parenting,
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.